we begin this program in New Zealand
where 40 people have been confirmed
killed and more than 20 wounded after
shootings at two mosques in the city of
Christchurch that's on the country's
South Island the first attack happened
at the al-nour mosque the second at the
Lynwood mosque eyewitnesses described
people fleeing in terror during Friday
prayers three men and a woman have been
apprehended police say they've diffused
a number of IEDs improvised explosive
devices found after the attacks
authorities have warned people to avoid
mosques across the country and for those
mosques to keep their doors closed Prime
Minister Jacinta Arden said it was one
of New Zealand's darkest days this is
what she had to say at a press
conference just moments ago it is clear
that this can now only be described as a
terrorist attack from what we know it
does appear to have been well planned -
explosive devices attached to suspects
vehicles have now been found and they
have been disarmed there are currently
four individuals who have been
apprehended but three connected to this
attack who are currently in custody
let's go live now to DW Samantha early
joining us in Christchurch Samantha we
heard the Prime Minister they're calling
this an act of terrorism what else did
she have to say in her press conference
that's right she did call it
unequivocally an act of terrorism
and she emphasized a lot that New
Zealand was chosen because it is a place
where diversity and inclusiveness and
and all those sorts and values are
strong she was very came to repeat that
she said this is not an insight for that
kind of ideology by that she means you
know ideology of
supremacy of wanting to inflict injury
on on certain groups of people she was
very very keen to express that New
Zealand was targeted and not because
this sort of ideology is supported here
but because it's not is the police
operations still ongoing our suspects
still at large we already have three men
in custody and a woman as well what do
we know about them and their possible
motives well we know about the most is a
it's been confirmed there is a 28 year
old Australian men as the I suppose main
suspect and the others are also yeah who
have been apprehended but we don't know
too much more about them at this stage
and yeah they also cannot rule out that
there might be more people involved in
this and that's why the police is still
urging caution
okay Christchurch was on lockdown is
that lockdown been lifted schools for
example we're told to shut their doors
that's right yeah that lockdown has been
gradually being lifted over the past
couple of hours schoolchildren have been
able to be picked up from school as well
as the hospital lockdown has stopped in
a lot of public buildings as well people
are slowly being able to make their way
home but authorities are encouraging
people to just stay home and not travel
if they don't need to so the feeling in
the city is still definitely very tense
and there's a lot of concern yeah okay
let's hear now from a two eyewitnesses
who were at one of the mosques during
their shooting and he if Herman and he's
given that car a glasses and he's
address of the military and his vagin
Michigan of the m16 plug one and it is a
seat belt of the another getting a gun
bullet bullet and he passed I said hey
what to do it and not took me he looking
a lot to me
he started it he started shooting and I
the people of the I cheated
the hues and the shooting under me I'm
running after that he goes inside and he
go one by one everybody killin and some
people died first we hide behind the
cars and you know under the car and then
when we see they're firing Stallone we
try to you know jump the fence and then
we hide next house to the mosque on this
side and
fighting with on and on you know
Samantha 40 people have been confirmed
killed more than 20 have been injured we
understand police are using all their
resources the resources to get officers
out onto the streets
how about emergency services how are
they coping in Christchurch right now
there's been a lot of praise from the
mayor of Christchurch and from the
citizens of Russia as to how the
emergency services has coped you like to
remember the police were also looking
out for their climate March which was
happening and Cathedral Square in the
city quite nearby while this was all
while this all started unfolding so a
huge police response all over
Christchurch and yeah the the mere
especially communing officers for their
bravery there you also know that
Christchurch had a significant
earthquake a years ago so you know these
response systems are quite well
practiced I guess but it's also yet
another trauma for the residents but
what can you tell us about
Christchurch's Muslim community have
they been the subject of attacks before
today nothing like this nothing at all
like this and lots of people are very
shocked that Muslims would be targeted
here in New Zealand
there have been reports of racist
attacks people but but nothing on this
scale and and certainly it's very
shocking the Muslim population here in
New Zealand is roughly just over 1% of
the total population so it's not a very
large community but it's a it is quite a
diverse community and from the latest
census data you see that about a quarter
of people who listed themselves as
Muslim in New Zealand were born here in
New Zealand and the other three quarters
and
Pacific Islands Asia and Middle Eastern
Africa so a really diverse community a
small community and one that the rest of
New Zealanders really wanting to show
solidarity with excellent okay police
are getting all their resources out on
to the streets right now how long will
this ongoing pre the police operation
last is it centered in Christchurch or
is it also taking place in other urban
centers across the country it is really
a nationwide operation so the Prime
Minister is pseudo alert liberal for for
terrorism has been raised from low to
high and that is to enable absolutely
all those resources to venues around the
country as they needed so that really
ants dip things up to the highest level
I think that they can and yeah we'll
definitely be seeing a strong police
operation I think continued for for
quite some time it's hard to tell you
know we have had reports of potentially
some situations developing in the past
few moments and in other cities too so
we will keep the close eye on that okay
other situations developing in other
cities do we know anything else about
that or or details slowly coming in on
that details are slowly coming in but it
appears that the train station at
Britomart which is in Auckland the the
most populous city up in the North
Island has been evacuated and the police
are responding to a situation there but
it's unclear what their situation is at
this stage or if it has anything to do
with what's happened in Christchurch
okay we'll find about more about that in
the hours ahead for now DWS Samantha
early in Christchurch thanks very much